This statistic here is for a one sample t test. This is just like the z tests
you learned in lesson nine. It's a one sample t test because we only have one
sample, with mean x bar. For the first part of this lesson, we'll focus on one
sample T tests and then later we'll focus on comparing two samples. We want to
know if the population that this sample comes from is significantly different
than the population with this mean. Therefore, the null hypothesis is that the
population mean is equal to some specified value. Mu naught, and the
alternative hypothesis can be either that mu is less than mu naught, greater
than mu naught, or just not equal to mu naught. When we calculate the t
statistic, the numerator is the difference between the sample mean and this
value, where the sample mean is the point estimate for the population mean mu,
and the denominator measures the amount of difference between the population
mean and mu naught That we would expect by chance. Again we have our alpha
levels which are written in the column headers of the t table. The t table
tells us the t critical values that mark the cut off point for the alpha
levels. If our t stastics is greater than these t critical values. Or if we get
a negative T statistic that is less than the negative T critical value cutting
off that alpha level, then we can reject the null.